[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine bien sûr il fallait que je
choisisse un sujet chaud dans
l'actualité la chasse à l'orignal vous
avez sûrement vu passer dans les
nouvelles ou même dans les journaux les
problématiques qui se vivent
présentement entre les chasseurs et les
personnes de la nation à niskabe
algonkin et les chasseurs a permis les
chasseurs sportifs ça fait un peu de
flammèche si c'est un euphémisme que je
peux utiliser
premièrement parce que dans les
dernières années on a fait vu un
marathon autour de la chasse de
l'orignal qui a été mis de l'avant par
la communauté à michnabe par plusieurs
communautés d'ailleurs pour pouvoir
donner une pause à l'orignal qui a des
problématiques de repropulation et comme
c'est un animal fort pour les amis
islamiques pour les Allemands
de prendre une rose pour la chasse à
l'orignal et de lancer une recherche
autour des raisons pourquoi l'orignal
est en disparition tout particulièrement
particulièrement dans le parc de la
véranderie ben ça va amené un rapport
qui avait déposé cette semaine qui est
super intéressant d'ailleurs je le
recommande pour ceux qui s'intéresse
parce que non seulement c'est un rapport
qui fait un état de la réalité de
l'orignal justement en tant que la
véranderie mais en plus c'est un rapport
qui était écrit en collaboration avec
les communautés à Michelin et a réunit
des savoirs ancestraux des savoirs des
aînés des observations faites par les
chasseurs donc des personnes qui sont
carrément sur le territoire depuis
toujours et qui ont pu l'observer
vraiment et puis donner des suggestions
et justement des recommandations pour la
protection de leur idéal
l'orignal c'est un des animaux qui sont
centrales à la culture des années
schnabé des Algonquins et je pense que
en même pré c'est la même chose qui a
été faite aussi pour le caribou en
mettant pause sur la chasse c'est pas
seulement les chasseurs sportifs qui
sont mis à l'arrêt c'est aussi beaucoup
les chasseurs autochton non il y a
non seulement comme un sacrifice qui est
faite aussi mais il y a aussi une
demande de participation de la
communauté
avoisinante de la communauté
à l'automne cependant on a vu des
menaces qui ont été proférées envers des
personnes à Nice qui se promenaient sur
le territoire parce que autant les
communautés autochtones ont des droits
ancestraux liés à la chasse qui sont
inaliénables qui sont dans la
Constitution autant une personne qui est
un chasseur commercial a un permis qui
va payer et qui veut avoir sa chasse
mais le truc c'est que c'est pas fait
une chasse de partage de territoire
c'est une chose de ces mots lourd donc
on a vu des chemins qui ont été barrés
on a vu des menaces proférées parce que
la forêt commence à être pas mal
comment il y a foule donc
malheureusement ça ça fait sortir le
pire dans l'homme et on a vu des menaces
des fois de même des personnes qui
étaient accompagnées de jeunes enfants
comme quoi on ne devait pas passer sur
ce lot là puisque le permis avait été
payé alors que quand une personne qui de
la nationale banking
traverse le territoire au travers son
territoire avec toutes ses droits donc
ces deux droits-là sont en train de
faire des frictions énormes et non
seulement ça le rapport
à souligné de des enjeux qui amènent
problématique auprès de la population
des orignaux et c'est la coupe
forestière et la chasse sportive donc
vous pouvez imaginer que en pointant du
doigt de industries qui sont extrêmement
importantes dans dans ces régions là
on ne se fera pas une des amis
uniquement au nom de l'orignal donc la
coupe forestière abusive c'est certain
que ça fait diminuer les populations les
zones de mise-bas ça ouvre en plus les
chemins forestiers ça ouvre la ficelle
justement au prédateurs qui vont suivre
les réunions qui vont probablement aussi
malheureusement nuire à d'autres
populations de cervidés qui vont
justement avoir des autoroutes après
l'attente qui s'en viennent chez eux
mais tout ça c'est aussi combien avec
deux idées c'est à dire l'idée de la
personne qui est en survivant sculptural
qui est en réconciliation aussi donc
processus de
réactualisation de sa culture de sa
langue aussi très important il y a une
sécurité alimentaire liée à l'animal qui
n'est pas vraiment le même problématique
pour des chasseurs sportifs
et même des fois ce sont des des
visions culturelles qui s'opposent je
pense beaucoup panache par exemple qu'on
met sur les voitures alors que la taille
de l'orignal comporte énormément de
ressources alimentaires qui vont être
perdus parce que le panache ou la tête
va exposer sur le devant d'une voiture
le panache lui-même sert
pour la fabrication d'outils bijoux
d'objets et là même d'oeuvre d'art et là
on va le voir sur souvent on fait sur un
mur ou mis sur la l'oeil le dessus d'une
voiture donc vous comprenez que juste ça
ça peut déjà devenir des des objets de
disputes ou de se regarder de loin
mais ça crée ces tensions là et ça va
s'augmenter de plus en plus à mesure que
les problématiques liées à la sécurité
alimentaire liée à la terre de
biodiversité et même lié à l'effet
domino qui va être ressenti par les
autres espèces je pense par exemple le
caribou qui est lui-même est
une perte de vitesse et bien de plus en
plus de personnes de la nation et nous
vont commencer à chasser leur idéal et
quand on chasse pas l'orignal on peut
aller pêcher le homard pour avoir des
viandes plus traditionnelles on peut
aller plus à une table donc ça va faire
un effet domino pour la sécurité
alimentaire parce qu'on va aller
chercher des viandes de bois qui sont
plus accessibles et qu'on risque d'être
surchassés parce qu'on veut donner un
répit et ce répit là comme il n'est pas
assez efficace par rapport à la lutte
aux autres effets c'est-à-dire la
déforestation ou même la chasse sportive
et bien ça peut avoir des effets
néfastes à long terme sur d'autres
espèces donc le rapport est très
intéressant parce qu'il comporte non
seulement
euh les observations des comportent
aussi des des solutions qui peuvent être
partagées non seulement par les
Premières nations entre amis schnabe et
d'autres nations mais aussi avec les
allocats pour que la pérennité de
l'espèce se fasse non seulement pour nos
enfants mais aussi pour les enfants des
autres nations autour de nous avec qui
on partage nos territoires donc je pense
que c'est un très bon rapport à lire
c'est aussi rempli de savoir de peuple
qui ont observé
c'est être vivant et qui veulent
justement en lien avec la responsabilité
qu'on a pour les septures générations et
bien s'assurer qu'il y a aussi une
protection des relations animales
végétales tout ce qui nous entoure
justement pour pouvoir s'assurer que on
ne soit pas les seuls à m'avoir
bénéficié mais que nos enfants aussi un
jour on auront la chance donc très
intéressant mais aussi très brûlant et
très propice à ouvrir aux commentaires
haineux ou menaces à la violence à la
discrimination
des préconçues parce qu'on en voit
malheureusement encore autour des
nouvelles et autour des commentaires
sous les articles c'est une réalité
malheureusement des médias sociaux mais
c'est aussi une réalité qui est appelée
à changer puisque les savoirs et aussi
les droits autochtones sont de plus en
plus reconnus et compris dans la
population canadienne donc
on va se garder la u ouvert on est très
intéressé par le sujet parce que c'est
un sujet qui parle quand même de la
solitude notre réconciliation puis des
enjeux qui touchent une communauté
autochtones pour les quelques
générations à venir donc n'hésitez pas à
partager cette vidéo n'hésitez pas non
plus à nous envoyer des questions et
surtout n'hésitez pas à lire le rapport
parce qu'il est très intéressant alors
je vous souhaite une belle semaine